hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the UN warns that climate biodiversity
and degradation goals will soon be Out
Of Reach unless the financing of
nature-based solutions more than doubles
The Prince and Princess of Wales are in
Boston ahead of his Earth shot prize
ceremony but their visit is overshadowed
by the palace race route
and the Mr Men and Little Miss family
has a new member find out why she's the
most environmentally aware yet
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now the United Nations
has warned climate biodiversity and
degradation goals will be Out Of Reach
unless investment in nature-based
Solutions is drastically ramped up now
before we go any further what we mean by
nature-based Solutions is the
sustainable management and use of
natural features and processes to tackle
socio-environmental challenges currently
about 127 billion pounds is invested in
nature-based Solutions around the world
each year but the UN says this needs to
more than double to 317 billion pounds a
year by 2025 that's about the size of
the entire Danish economy at the moment
just 17 of this investment comes from
private companies but the UN says this
must change if we are to hit climate
targets and it's calling for the private
sector to combine Net Zero with nature
positive Investments the report also
calls for an end to climate harmful
subsidies from the government which are
estimated to be three to seven times the
size of investments in nature-based
Solutions
science correspondent Thomas Moore joins
us now hi Thomas so things have to
change the UN says
well as ever money can be good or bad
and so that's definitely true when it
comes to Nature so on one side
government subsidies for things like
cattle ranching and soil production can
result in deforestation in the Amazon
but on the other incentives for Farmers
to farm with nature can bring Wildlife
back onto the fields store more carbon
in the soil and so on but this report
says governments can't do all this on
their own they're encouraging private
companies to step up so they need to
look at their supply chains to make sure
they're sustainable make sure they're
not buying beef or palm oil from
rainforest areas to make sure that
they're investing in nature positive
ideas such as replanting seagrass
Meadows or restoring peat bogs the
problem is that politicians often see
nature-based Solutions as soft so while
they were queuing up to be seen at the
climate conference in in Egypt there
will be very few at the big biodiversity
conference the UN is holding in Montreal
starting next week this is called cop15
and it's trying to get Global agreement
for a blueprint for conservation and it
is much needed because right now the
planet is suffering the largest loss of
life since the dinosaurs
okay Thomas thank you so much
so as Thomas was saying their cop 15
starts next week it's a bit like buses
you wait all year for One Cop Summit and
then two come along at once first cop 27
in Egypt last month and now this one
don't be confused by the Numbers though
it's official and slightly long-winded
title is the 15th Conference of the
parties to the United Nations convention
on biological diversity so while last
month's conference in shamal Sheikh was
the 27th Summit to focus on climate
change this is the 15th to focus on
bringing the Earth's biodiversity under
control and to start to turn things
around it was actually scheduled to take
place in Quin Min in China two years ago
the first part took place online in
October of last year where the Quin Min
Declaration was signed committing to put
the world's biodiversity on a path to
recovery by 2030. now although China
retains its presidency the second part
of the meeting has moved to the Canadian
city of Montreal and will take place
from next Monday the 5th of December
until Saturday the 17th of December and
we will of course keep you right across
the latest developments throughout the
summit
now also making climate news today a ban
on building onshore wind farms since
2016 has added 800 million pounds to
household bills this winter that's
according to new research the energy and
climate change intelligence unit says
that without the ban enough turbines
could have been built to power one and a
half million homes this winter
and cut the need for gas power plants
India has taken over its role as chair
of the G20 leading economies today and
says it will put climate top of the
agenda the country has made significant
moves towards its climate goals but is
still one of the world's top emitters
experts expect India to use its one-year
presidency to push for more money to
help developing countries transition to
clean energy and adapt to a wounded
world
the French President Emmanuel macron has
criticized sweeping new subsidies on
American-made Green Technology while on
a visit to the US the Biden
Administration says its signature
climate law will go a long way to curb
climate change but the EU says the tax
credits go against International Trade
law and will harm European companies
well the French President is not the
only one making a trip across the
Atlantic this week The Prince and
Princess of Wales are in Boston ahead of
the awards ceremony for Prince William's
earthshot prize but their visit has been
somewhat overshadowed by the Buckingham
Palace race route our Royal
correspondent Laura bundock is traveling
with them well Boston is facing
significant climate change challenges
neighborhoods here are under threat as a
result of the city's rising sea levels
they have become vulnerable to climate
change caused flooding to storm surgeons
to more hot days in fact scientists
predict that within 80 years they'll see
around this city will have risen by over
three feet such is the scale of the
problem emergency Solutions are being
sought and here in Boston they're
looking at nature-based Solutions one of
the finalists of last year's Earth shot
prize Prince William's big environmental
Awards uh one of those finalists was a
company called living sea walls and what
this company does is create panels which
mimic natural habitat formations things
like rock pools and mangroves these
panels can then be fitted to existing
Waterfront structures or attached to new
ones and the idea is is that they
promote Marine
biodiversity it is a natural solution
other things taking place in this city
are in an area called Somerville Green
Town Labs is this huge collaboration
bringing together green startups with
investors and also with big corporates
as well and the idea is they come up
with more solutions to climate change
this is the largest climate startup in
North America and it is Big Business
Green Town Labs have in total managed to
raise four billion dollars of funding so
these are just two of the examples and
two other places the Princeton Princess
of Wales are visiting here in Boston to
very different solutions to the climate
change crisis that is facing this city
and don't forget our weekly climate Show
with Tom heat will be on this weekend
when Tom will be looking at the issue of
hydrogen power you can watch the show
here on Sky News at 3 30 in the
afternoon or at 7 30 in the evening on
Saturday and Sunday and if you have any
questions about climate change that you
want answered send them all to us using
this QR code and we will try to answer
as many as we can on Tom's show right
before you go let's just leave you with
the news that there's a new Little Miss
in town and she's the most
environmentally aware yet Little Miss
wasteless repairs the holes in her socks
instead of throwing them away she reuses
her carrier bags for her shopping
doesn't buy more than she needs and
collects rain water so water her garden
she's been launched with the aim of
encouraging children to be more engaged
with sustainability and talk to their
parents about being more green at home
she is the 95th Mr Man and Little Miss
character to be created since Roger
Hargreaves created the brand in 1971
with the launch of can you guess
Mr tickle now that's all from me
Kimberly Leonard for today thanks very
much for watching
[Music]